so dr. Ellis cough it's it's such a
pleasure to have you here today and as
we think about you know Stanford heroes
your contributions have been tremendous
but I I wanted to start at the beginning
we have a lot of young people here today
and I was fascinated by the fact that
you grew up in the Bay Area you grew up
in San Francisco went to UC Berkeley
went away for a little bit came back to
Stanford so would love to hear a little
bit of the origin story okay well as you
said I grew up right in San Francisco
it's a very different place now than it
was then
and I was always interested in math and
science even though at that time even
more so than today it was not considered
the thing that women should be doing but
I persevered and I went to Berkeley and
I majored in math were there early
influences that that pushed you along
that you know I don't think so I think
that my parents my mother was a
housewife my father was a lawyer
they had no particular reason to push me
toward engineering and so forth but they
were certainly encouraging they whatever
I wanted to do was find with them which
i think is really important for young
people so I went off to Berkeley I
majored in math and when I finished
there I thought about going to graduate
school but I decided I really wasn't
ready because I didn't want to make that
kind of commitment to studying and so I
decided to get a job and I had a close
friend who had graduated from Stanford
and we decided to move to the Boston
area because my father grew up here and
I came to Boston and I went to look for
a job and I couldn't find a good job as
a mathematician which is not surprising
since you really need more than an
undergraduate degree in math to do
interesting math but I was offered a job
as a programmer and at this point I
didn't even know computers existed I had
never heard of a computer and they were
hiring people like me who knew nothing
about computers because there was no
computer science department there was
nobody graduating from college who knew
program so they would hire anybody that
they thought might be able to do the job
and I went to work at a place called The
MITRE corporation and my first day on
the job I was handed a Fortran manual
and I was asked to write a program to do
some little thing that they described to
me I forgotten what it was and I
discovered this field that I knew
nothing about that was really
interesting and really fit my abilities
and so I was off to the races then
that's how I discovered computer science
I worked at mitre for a year and then I
switched and worked at Harvard for a
year at Harvard I worked on a machine
translation project and I was actually
maintaining a big program it was a in
those days used to have printouts and
that printout was 2 or 3 inches thick
and my job was to maintain that code and
it was written in machine language so
one of the two benefits of that job I
learned how the machine works so I
learned about computer architecture and
I also learned about what it means to
write good and bad code because when
you're maintaining somebody else's code
you certainly see both the good points
and the bad points anyway part through
way through that that period and working
in this job I decided to go to graduate
school because I felt that although I
was learning a lot
I was basically self-taught and I think
it seemed like I could make a lot more
progress going to school
and I decided to go back to Stanford
because I felt like I was time to come
back to California so that's sort of how
I got into the field and when did you
come back to Palo Alto them I came here
in 1963 so I worked for two years and
then I went back to graduate school how
do you think so you know a lot of
undergraduate students are thinking
about this in this moment right now do I
go straight into graduate school or do I
take a moment to go out and work for a
little bit and then come back it sounds
like this this process of actually
getting out and working for a little bit
was very influential and in what you
decide to study can you talk a little
bit more about that I think it was
obviously crucial for me if I had gone
on the way I was going when I finished
my bachelor's degree
I probably would never have ended up
where I ended up I think that in a way
what happened because I went and looked
for a job is that a door opened that I
hadn't expected to see and actually I
think these kinds of moments happen in
many people's careers you think you're
on certain path you discover along the
way some opportunity presents itself and
you move in a different direction and it
just changes the way your life is as far
as the question of should you go on for
a graduate degree right away or is it
okay to go and work instead I always
tell my students that you know it's a
personal decision what you're looking
for in a career is something that you're
good at and something that you like
because if you don't have both of those
things you're not going to be successful
but exactly what that's going to be for
you it depends on you and you have to
find a path and figure it out for
yourself and so there isn't a right or
wrong answer here it's just you just
sort of follow your nose and things will
happen I love that so so you arrived
here in Palo Alto 1963 for many of you
in the room you all know that this is a
Palo Alto is is ground zero for many
very well-known startups in 1965 there
was a very well-known startup that
started in Palo Alto called The Grateful
Dead on High Street and so that's the
period that you're coming here to
Stanford so I would love to know what
what was Stanford like in that period
and and then what was the computer
science department like so Stanford was
a backwater
I had been going to Berkeley Berkeley is
so full of energy there's so much going
on there and it just felt like I just in
the middle of nowhere and you have to
understand that it was much less
developed than than it is now you know
there were still apricot orchards in
this area so it was a different time but
they had the Grateful Dead they didn't
have the group yet
and you know the whole business of
startups wasn't really around not the
way we know it today there were HP
existed you know so there were similar
sort of more electrical engineering
things SR I existed I think but there
wasn't a hell of a lot going on but as
far as a place to study was concerned it
was good there wasn't even a computer
science department yet when I got here
it was just a program it was very small
I don't actually remember how many
people were in my entering class but it
was probably five or something like that
really small nevertheless the classes
that I took had quite a few people
attending them and I remember fondly the
class I took on compilers in which the
class took over the machine room in the
evening because it was the only way we
had our turnaround in time since that
was the day of batch processing and
otherwise she would submit a deck and
you know two days later you might get
back the answer about whether there was
a bug in your program and you were the
you were the first woman to get a PhD in
computer science from Stanford yes were
there challenges there what did it feel
different or where you're used to being
a woman in a pioneering woman in your
field might as well I was used to being
one of you know one or two women in
Berkeley when I was taking my math
course as I was usually one or two women
in those classes so that part did not
feel unusual I actually found Stanford
very friendly I mean I felt the students
were helpful to one another when I
talked about what was going on in the
compiler course that was all of us
together so I found it a very supportive
environment fantastic how did you decide
what you wanted to study once you were
in
computer science program so my
recollection which I am completely
certain must be totally false is that on
the day I arrived I met John McCarthy
walking up the steps to the computer
science building and I asked him whether
I could be an RA now I very much doubt
that this actually true because I don't
think I would have had the courage to
have asked that question on the other
hand I also think that they expected me
to go into AI because I had been working
at Harvard on this machine translation
program although I wasn't doing any of
the technical work I was just
maintaining the program at any rate I
started working with John McCarthy and I
did my thesis in AI I came to realize
partway through that I really didn't
want to continue in AI can you tell us a
little bit what was AI back then so AI
back then was different then the idea
and AI was that you would design
programs that worked the way people did
so I was particularly interested in
machine learning but the idea was that
the machine would somehow learn just
like a person would learn and that was a
really hard way to do things and it
wasn't terribly effective and so it's
totally different now you know what
happened with machine learning and
especially deep learning is it changed
all of AI and so things are really quite
different in AI now and the what's going
on today is totally different than what
was happening then so interesting that
let's turn to your Turing award citation
which reads for contributions to
practical and theoretical foundations of
programming language and system design
especially related to data abstraction
fault tolerance and distributed
computing so so then I'm gonna tell you
the story of what happened as I finished
up at Stanford great so I had decided
that I wanted to move out of the field
of AI I also decided that I wanted to do
that after I finished my PhD because I
thought it would be faster to finish and
after all the point of being in graduate
school and getting your PhD is to finish
up and go on and do something with it
so I finished my PhD in AI i it was on a
program to play chess in games and in
those days chess was a sort of a killer
app for AI the reason was that computers
were not very powerful and they just
could not do the kind of search that's
needed to figure out which move to make
and so that was why I was working in
that area for my PhD topic anyway I
finished my PhD and nobody was willing
to offer me a good job as a faculty
member and so I ended up going back to
Boston and working for the same company
that I had worked for originally mitre
corporation it was all my husband's
fault
because I wanted to move back to Boston
because he lived there so I got to mitre
and it was actually very fortunate that
I did not go on to a faculty position
right away because it's not easy to
start up as a new member of the faculty
and at the same time in your teaching
courses and you've all these obligations
and you're also trying to change fields
and I was making a major change of field
from AI into computer systems and being
at mitre gave me the freedom to do this
I was in a research position now and the
first project I worked on was a time
sharing system which time sharing was a
hot topic at the time and I worked on
that for a couple of years and then I
was at ignitor and they do research for
the government and I was asked to look
into this problem that the government
was interested in namely what to do
about the software crisis so the
software crisis was people would build
big programs and they wouldn't work
they'd spend hundreds of man you know
hundreds of millions of dollars hundreds
of man years and in the end they'd have
to scrap the whole thing and actually in
the 60s the 70s the 80s you could read
in the newspaper about these Fiasco's
companies such and such you know spend
all this money and now they've had to
throw the whole thing away so the
software crisis was a really big problem
and I was asked to start thinking about
this and so I started to look into this
field it's called programming
methodology of course I read all the
papers
existed and there were some really good
people working in that field there was
Edsger Dijkstra Tony Hoare Dave Parnas I
mean these were very good people and
they were writing papers about how do
you break up a program into pieces so
that you can reason about it
the problem that they were worried about
was software programs are huge they were
huge then you know millions of lines of
code they're even bigger today there's
no way that you can make sense of
something that big you have to have a
way of breaking it up into small pieces
that you can work on independently
reason about independently and that's
somehow you put the whole thing together
and it works and nobody knew how to do
that so they were talking about things
they called modules but partes said I
don't know what they are there's these
things called modules but I don't know
how to describe them and they were also
worrying about how do you do design and
Nicholas Barrett wrote a paper about
top-down design and he sort of talked
about it but it was unrelated to the
software structure that existed
underneath anyway I read all these
papers and I realized that I had
invented a software methodology when I
was working on my first project the
venous system because that was a
complicated project at the time and I
was very worried about how my small team
of programmers would manage to build all
that software and haven't worked in a
short period of time and so what I did
was I sort of broke the rules in the way
the programs were being built at the
time in those days there tended to be
lots of global variables and then lots
of code and the code interacted through
the global variables and that didn't
actually work all that well so what I
decided to do was to say that I was
going to not have any global variables I
was going to partition them into
discrete units and there would be some
code responsible for each partition and
the only way that code could interact
with one another and that you can get
access to the Global's was by calling
operations that the partition that was
in charge of those Global's provided for
you so I had this notion of what I
called a partition or a multi operation
module that had some data hidden inside
and a bunch of operations that you would
do
to interact with that and I wrote this
up so this is a a fundamental concept do
you encounter in a CS 106 a class well
we hadn't quite got the info so this was
admire so here I am at mitre and we knew
I had written a paper on my operating
system Venus and I submitted it to s OSP
which is the top conference in computers
in systems and I presented it at this
conference and unknown to me there were
people from MIT kind of looking for
women so what had happened is title 9
was on the verge of being passed and
title 9 although it has to do with
athletics actually started to open the
door for women and the president of MIT
Jerry Wiesner I think was interested in
having them hire some women and the
electrical engineering department which
was all that existed at that point had
gotten the message and so they were kind
of looking and the chair of my session
was a professor at MIT and there were a
couple of other senior professors in the
audience and as a result of this talk
they asked me to apply for a faculty
position and so I moved to MIT in the
fall of 1972 and this was actually a
really good time to make this move for
me because at that point I was totally
wrapped up in the program methodology
part of the question in particular I
wanted to understand what can we do to
help people figure out how to break
their problem when they're doing design
into a bunch of modules that make sense
and nobody knew how to do that and the
benefit of being a professor was that I
could do my own I can define my own
research direction and I had a research
direction that I was really interested
in pursuing and this was consuming the
sort of light of day I was thinking
about this all the time this is during
my first year at MIT so I'm teaching a
course and I'm thinking about this
research and the way I have always done
my research is to focus very hard during
the day and then I stopped working like
a home in the evening and I don't work
okay but the thought I was doing during
the day it's in my subconscious
and so I'm still thinking about things
even if I'm not thinking about them and
a common situation for me would be that
when I'm driving into work in the
morning and I'm kind of thinking about
what am I going to do today all of a
sudden I see a solution to a problem I
hadn't been able to solve the night
before the day before so the
subconscious the power of the
subconscious and also making sure you're
not too tired is very effective way of
doing your work so I'm thinking about
this question about how to do modularity
and all of a sudden I had this insight
I thought of data abstraction so before
I had talked about these modules with
multiple operations but they were
disconnected from any notion that might
make sense for design and when I saw
that this could be connected to the
notion of an abstract data type that
made a huge difference because people
already understood about procedures as a
way of breaking things into modules
those are abstract things like a sort
routine which is sort of independent of
how you implement it but it's an
abstract idea same idea here I could
have a set I could have a stack I could
have a tree or whatever it is I could
think about that as an abstract concept
I could invent it during design and then
later I could figure out how to
implement it so it gave me a way not
only to break things up into much bigger
more effective modules than what we had
before but it also connected to a design
process where I could think about things
abstractly and then focus on how to
implement them as a second step so that
was this wonderful idea I had in 1972
sometime or 1973 which was the invention
of the abstract data type fantastic and
that's sort of a foundational element
that we see that influences how we teach
computer science today at a very basic
level yes
so taking us to a more modern era where
we're we're also what I'd love to cover
one of your other areas of study which
was in distributed computing and you
worked on consensus algorithms
particularly with your grad student
miguel castro and i was particularly
drawn to this paper around practical
Byzantine fault tolerance because it's
been very influential in a very new area
of cryptocurrency yeah and so before we
ask you about the research I think it's
important to know if you own any
cryptocurrency I absolutely do not Oh
cryptocurrency I feel like one of the
you know things that happened as we
became more and more civilized as that
we learned how to control curve
currencies so that there are a lots of a
gambling mechanism and more of a you
know they have some value associated
with them so I'm not very interested in
crypto currencies some people would say
Bitcoin has some some actual value but
but we can do a fluctuates widely it
does it does so so I'd love to
understand more around around how you
became interested in consensus
algorithms and for the lay people in the
room what what is this okay so we've
dropped way ahead so I'm gonna continue
my story okay so after I invent a data
abstraction I then spent many years
designing a programming language called
clue which was the first language that
could support a data abstraction as a
built in concept in the language and
ultimately clue together with the work
of Alan Kay on small talk and work that
followed on from that is what what
object-oriented programming is all about
and so then job when it came along
picked this up and put it into the
mainstream meanwhile around about 1978
or so when I finished the work on clue I
was looking around for the next research
project and I happen to read a paper by
Bob Kahn who is one of what long with
them Cerf is one of the people who
invented the internet and Bob in this
paper talked about his dream about
distributed computing the idea was that
I would have programs that would have
components running on many computers
connected by a network and this seemed
like a really interesting idea but
nobody knew how to do it so I thought
gee there's a really interesting
research topic and so I decided to
pintu distributed computing so I
switched the main focus of my group in
ninth in the 1980s to distributed
systems and one of the things that was
interesting in working in distributed
systems was that remote file systems
came into existence at that time and I
was a little disturbed about remote file
systems because in the old days when you
had your files on your computer if your
computer was up your files were
accessible on the other hand once you
had a remote file system there were two
reasons why you might not get to your
files you know your computer might be
down but maybe your computer is working
just fine but you can't either access
that system is the Internet's down or
that computer has failed and this seemed
undesirable and so I started to think in
the 80s about how to solve that problem
and I worked with a student whose name
was Brian okie on a precursor to the
work you're talking about which was how
to build replication systems the way you
saw this is by having many copies of the
data but of course you have to manage
that carefully because if there are
failures of concurrency you want to make
sure that the answers you get tomorrow
or you know the same is what you think
you saw today so you don't lose data it
doesn't get confused and so forth so
Brian and I worked on a replication
algorithm that handled what are called
benign failures or crash failures the
idea was your computers either up and
working or it's completely silent you
don't have to worry about it and
similarly for networks the messages are
delivered or if they're bad they're
recognizably bad or everything's you
know or they're completely silent again
okay so a simpler failure model than
what we have today and with Brian I
designed a replication technique that
worked in that world and that was in the
80s and then in the 90s of I had this
very talented student in my group named
Miguel Castro and the Yale was looking
for a thesis topic and I said to him why
don't you go out and look for the
request for proposals the RFPs that
DARPA has put out and see if theirs
something that strikes your fancy out
there and by then now we're in reaching
the information age you know where lots
of people had access to computers they
had computers in their homes they were
connecting and so forth and there was
already we could already see all the bad
behavior that we see so much of today so
people hacking into computers you know
reading your messages changing your
messages faking your messages you know
all that sort of stuff was becoming to
the surface and so DARPA which is the
defense agency research arm was asking
for people to look for things that might
help with this problem and Miguel
thought why don't we work on Byzantine
fault tolerant replication so I think
this came from true places I think
partly in my group we were maybe the
only group in the country that actually
understood how benign fault tolerance
worked because this stuff was wasn't
really well sort of understood
throughout the computer science
community but the people in my group
they all knew it because we had
developed this way of solving the
problem so that was in his mind and that
enabled him to think about how can we
take this next step to this harder thing
so here's what a Byzantine failure is
instead of having the computer up or
down the computers up but it is acting
badly and it might even be acting badly
in a way you can't detect so you might
say to it store my file and it comes
back and says files stored but in fact
it through your file away or it
corrupted it or something like that so
misbehaved and similarly the network is
malicious now we have all the kinds of
problems we know exist on the network
where people fake their messages and
they corrupt your messages and they
steal your messages and so forth and so
on so you had to worry about these
attacks coming in both fronts and so we
started to work on this problem and
because we knew about how to do the
other kind of fault tolerance
that gave us a big leg up because we can
think about this as something we could
build on top of we can extend though
that that way of doing things to handle
this much more difficult system and so
Miguel and I worked on that we started
maybe around 1996 we finished that work
around 2000 and that's the system you're
talking about called practical Byzantine
fault tolerance the reason the word
practical is in there is because my
group has always been an engineering
group we want to make things work in a
way that you could really use in
practice there was work already in
theoretical Byzantine fault tolerance
but those were not algorithms that you
would really want to use if you were
really building a system so we were
looking for something practical and so
here it is about 2,000 and the Yale and
I have finished this work and we're
asking ourselves the question will
anybody ever use this stuff you know
that was one question and also we
wondered about how many replicas you had
to have in order to do Byzantine fault
tolerance if you want to survive F
failures so F bad computers you have to
have three F plus one replicas so it's a
big multiplication factor so we thought
well maybe a sequel to F equal three
that was about as much as we thought
could be stood and we thought maybe this
might be used for a key distribution
center which is where the keys the
public/private keys that people use on
the internet come from one thing I
should mention is around 2000 finally
practical the the the simple benign
failure stuff that we done started to
appear in products so that was a big lag
factor of about 12 years from the time
that work had been done till the time it
started to appear so you know even
though we couldn't see where this would
go we might felt hopeful that it would
go somewhere you know 10 years down the
road so that's where we are we stopped
working on this problem Miguel and I
Miguel went off to work for Microsoft
Research in Cambridge Engel
I continued in my work at MIT and then
and I think it was my 2008 is that right
the Bitcoin paper came out and that is
the killer app for Byzantine fault
tolerance so the result has been lots
and lots of research has been building
on the stuff that Miguel and I did back
in the in the night late 1990s so
everyone's Satoshi Nakamoto right here
he had a different technique why do we
yes well I wanted to switch directions a
little bit if that's okay I know that
you have actually you have a son yes who
also is a computer scientist right I
think it's also wonderful that you've
written a paper together but I so so to
to kind of general questions here a the
path to getting to a point where you get
to write a paper with your son what's
that like but secondly serve as a mother
as you think about raising children
today in this sort of computer science
era how should people think about that
let me take the first one first yeah
about the second one so I feel that in a
way my husband is responsible for the
way my son came out because whenever I
was out of town on business which
happened from time to time they would go
to friendlies which no longer exists but
it was a chain of restaurants and they
would sit at the counter and have their
food and work on math problems and my
son is a much better mathematician than
I ever was and so he went on to he went
to Harvard as an undergraduate he
started off in math he actually ended up
in computer science but he's always been
more theoretical than I am and so he
ended up in theoretical computer science
when we did that work together
this was on secret sharing which I is
another sort of crypto kind of thing and
he was a sort of the crypto the the
theoretical side of this and I was the
more practical side of this so I don't
feel I get much recent but you know I'm
not really responsible for the fact that
yeah I think my husband gets the credit
for that but I can tell you that it is a
fabulous experience to be able to do
this kind of work with it with a child I
mean it's wonderful and then as we as we
think about how tech is now so
integrated into our world and for you to
have seen the that technology has become
increasingly pervasive in our lives I'm
curious to know what are you most
optimistic about in the world and then
what are you worried about and you could
take either direction well I'll I'll
start with the good stuff ok ok so it's
clear that computers are doing a lot of
good stuff for us and you know one thing
that comes to mind right away is elderly
people in their homes who can now have
sensors that will detect there's
problems even being able to use remote
medicine I'm not talking about AI now
I'm talking about just being able to
talk to somebody or take up advice and
so forth you know you think of any field
and you can find ways that our computers
are healthy medicine is an easy one to
think of but there are many of them so
you can see many of these benefits
coming along unfortunately you can see
many problems and the problems are what
worried me more I think about them more
than I think about the benefits and I
worry about things like fake news I
worry about job displacement I worry
about spread of bad stuff on the
Internet
I worry about the compartmentalization
of communities that sort of reinforce
one another's views there are just lots
and lots of problems now in the days
when this technology was being developed
I think to some extent people were very
naive
but maybe they were also a little like
blinder than they should have been
because I can remember people saying oh
we shouldn't have these people that are
developing chat rooms be at all
responsible for the content that people
are putting into their chat rooms
because that would slow down development
and get in their way but you know if we
thought about it then I think we could
have seen what was coming and I worry
about that and I think that we're facing
a very difficult time now it's always
difficult when you have a displacing
technology which i think is the
information age is a really displacing
technology it takes time for people to
adjust and learn how to live with that
technology some of the worries about job
displacement are probably maybe not an
issue because always in the past other
jobs have come along to make up for the
jobs that are missing I don't know but I
worry about the ethical issues the this
whole issue about privacy versus free
speech versus security all of that stuff
and I think some of these problems have
technology that can help but they're
bigger than technology it's going to
require changes to laws tables the way
we think about things so I worry about
that stuff
does it change them the way we ought to
educate our engineers and computer
scientists I think that we should be
teaching ethics to our students I think
we should bring you up these questions I
think we should tell people who are
doing innovative work especially in
artificial intelligence I mean every
people are working in security that's
been an issue for a long time but I
think people developing AI should be
thinking about these problems and
thinking about ways to counteract them
and their systems to the extent that
that's possible so yeah I think we
should be teaching this stuff fantastic
with that I would like to open up
questions to the audience what do you
think about the bias that is associated
with the AI in how we is Nutini as we
can actually what do you think about the
bias that is knitted to a AG systems and
how do you think incidents in the
ass-end as people we can actually take
action to eliminate this bias Nick I
think this is really this is a question
about bias and I believe you're talking
about stuff like the extremely naive
statements that were made when they
started to apply machine learning to
hiring and they would say oh this is
going to get rid of all the bias in the
hiring which is totally false because of
course the training data reflects the
bias of the people who made their
decisions previously and so it goes
right into the algorithms the way to
counteract this is I think to be aware
of it and make sure that you are
counteracting the bias in the training
data so that this will be reflected in
the decision making I think you probably
also have to keep watching out for the
decisions that the algorithms are making
and checking them against you know what
kinds of decisions are these and are
they the right kind of decisions I mean
it's actually interesting it at MIT I
worked for a while as an associate
provost where I was in charge of
diversity on the faculty and what's
really important when you're in a
position like that is to collect the
data and analyze the data so you know
you want to know what was the applicant
pool how did this pool get reflected in
the people who are interviewed how did
the interviews get reflected in the
people who were hired how did that all
work out
so you wouldn't want a lot of that kind
of analysis going on as well so that's
what I think you can do there doesn't
exactly how you keep the bias out of the
training data that's it
interesting question and it's another
point by the way as I understand that
people don't really understand how those
learning algorithms work so as they come
to understand them better and better I
think this will also help with that
problem but I'm glad you brought that up
I mean that's an early example of how
people were just dead wrong about what
that algorithm was going to accomplish
so this is like an amazing perspective
that you're providing I haven't even
thought about object-oriented
programming being invented and to my my
question is you've seen the growth in
our capabilities
does that make you optimistic or more or
less up or less optimistic about how far
computers should be able to go versus
what humans for example are able to do
if you've seen it from like nothing so
there it is now and so do you have me it
wasn't the Stone Age yeah did that make
you more or less optimistic about the
limits of computer science so as I
understand your question you are
thinking about this this sort of the
ultimate AI question of can a computer
be as good as a person or something you
know mimic a person I don't know how to
answer that question I don't think so
but maybe that's just wishful thinking I
don't see computers having the
creativity that people have
I don't know
I haven't got a crystal ball here but I
hope that in fact computers will not be
able to be people I think we all hope
that my question is can you think of a
time in your career where someone you
deeply admired or respected advised you
to do something but you decided to or
chose to do something totally different
how did you come to that decision and
how did you feel at that time so this
question is sort of related the question
is did I ever have somebody who advised
me to do one thing and I decided to
disregard the advice and do another I
think in some sense my whole life has
been like this so if you think about you
know Here I am in high school and girls
aren't supposed to be interested in math
but I didn't let that stop me from
taking all the math and science courses
I could and there's just been a kind of
a continuing story here and I've always
kind of wondered why it was that I was
able to do that when a lot of women were
not able to do that and I don't have the
answer to that I have a sense of humor I
often think stuff is funny when other
people might get put off by it I don't
think but I think I may have been lucky
as well I never had any of the sort of
horrible things that sometimes women
report happened to me I don't know why
so in answer to your question though
there's another thing I wanted to say
which is when it comes to advising
faculty I feel it's extremely important
and I think this must apply all over the
place
but I'm thinking here in particular at a
university we have junior faculty or
trying to get tenure and there are
senior people trying to look out for
them and I think it's a big mistake for
senior people to start telling junior
people what to do because in the end you
have to be responsible for yourself and
if somebody tells you to do something
and you do it and it doesn't work out
you know they're responsible and
furthermore I actually believe that the
future belongs to the
people and they often have much better
ideas about what to do then the more
senior people do although I think what
I'm hearing from you though is you were
just this ultimate renegade I I've no
idea
you should just call you something
you're an unapologetic renegade and I
think that's that probably answers your
question of she felt very good about the
decisions that she's making which is
wonderful
yes primarily as a researcher but how do
you figure out what problems are worth
solving
and what spending like half a decade you
seem very useful Barbara you've been an
incredible problem picker and in
figuring out so where to where to point
your career so how do you do that I have
no idea I mean look I feel like I was
lucky in a way so I got into the field
early I mean of course at that time it
was all very confusing because nobody
knew how to do anything but when I saw
that program methodology problem it was
clear that was a hugely important
problem and to the you know when you can
see a problem that's in hugely important
that's a great thing to work on I happen
to be on a panel with some Nobel Prize
winners a couple of years ago and that
question came up how do you find
problems to work on and what they said
is what you do you pay a lot of
attention to what's going on around you
and every time you read a paper or
listen to a talk you ask questions you
know so you say what didn't they do
what's wrong you know what could be
better and that way you find things
somehow that helps you find things that
are directions to go in I mean actually
that doesn't match my story very well
because in fact I saw Bob Kahn pose a
problem but still that's another thing I
do I'm a very critical reader and I also
got very good at understanding what I
didn't
No which is almost more important than
knowing what you do know because then
you can see where the holes are in your
reasoning and when I read papers I see
the holes and their reasoning and that
often gives you an idea of which
direction you should go in but I don't
know you know I can't really answer that
question I just you know you look for
good problems don't do incremental work
but look for things that look like
they're going to be important and then
try to be honest in your research and
really think deeply and figure out what
you understand and what has yet to be
worked on you'd make an incredible
venture capitalist so with that I think
we will wrap it up and please join us in
thanking dr. Barbara